- [Theo] Umm.
(laughing)
(jazz lounge music)
- What are you doing?
Well, but see this isn't even fully true.
Oh, okay, yeah it is.
- It's gotta be... (marker on paper)
- No.
- [Theo] Oh.
- I do use that one a lot.
I also use, that one a lot.
- Oh really?
(laughing)
One, two, three.
- I love running on my
own when I can go slow,
but not when I have to
run with Theo, so fast.
(laughing)
- Can I say that?
- Sure.
(laughing)
What did you say?
Oh nice, great.
Perfect.
And my writing looks like
that of a six year old boy.
These are hard questions.
They're hard questions 'cause, I guess--
- There are so many.
He is so talented.
- [Theo] No, no.
As in there's lots of
different answers, isn't there?
- It's in Atlanta in
the hot heat. (laughing)
- (laughing) okay.
- Looks good, it's very--
- Stinky.
(trumpet blare)